bonsoir voici les titres de l'actualité
de ce 12 avril pour l'humanitaire comme
pour le militaire les pays membres de
l'otan font bloc nous verrons en albanie
en macédoine et nous évoquons la vie
quotidienne des belgradois et l'action
des séparatistes de lucciana au kosovo
avec un document inédit tourné au kosovo
et puis à 20 heures le président de la
république monsieur jacques chirac
interviendra en direct sur cette antenne
fin de campagne électorale en algérie
avec toujours un favori pour l'élection
jeudi du président marc public soucieux
bouteflika protestations chez elf à pau
un plan de suppression d'emplois doit
être annoncée sur le site de pau dans
les pyrénées-atlantiques
aujourd'hui il y à bruxelles les
ministres des affaires étrangères des 19
pays membres de l'otan étaient réunis et
c'est sans surprise que les
représentants des pays engagés dans les
frappes contre la serbie ont réaffirmé
leur détermination dans la poursuite de
celle ci tandis que le secrétaire
général de l'otan déclaré je le cite
nous avons la justice et le droit de
notre côté et slobodan milosevic père et
il sait qu'il perd fin de citation des
propos de monsieur solane compte rendu
de cette réunion à laquelle participait
la socata bêta des états unis madeleine
albright avec nos envoyés spéciaux
jean-marc ellouze olivier journée après
19 jours d'opérations militaires il
fallait faire le point et ce matin au
siège de l'otan à bruxelles autour du
secrétaire général javier solana
les ministres des affaires étrangères
des dix neuf pays de l'alliance se sont
surtout efforcé d'adapter dans l'unité
leur stratégie à la nouvelle donne dans
les balkans unités sur le message numéro
un résumé ici par radier cela n'a pas de
changement de cap
l'europe ne marchandera pas ses valeurs
avec milosevic cohésion aussi sur le
message numéro 2 souligner ici par le
français hubert védrine les frappes
aériennes ne sont pas une fin en soi il
faut dès maintenant réfléchir aux
conditions politiques
qui demain permettront avec la
participation de la russie et dans le
cadre des nations du vie de ramener la
stabilité dans les balkans en revanche
pour définir le futur statut du kosovo
et la chaîne de commandement de la
future force de paix français également
d'un côté américain et britannique de
l'autre doivent encore harmoniser leurs
positions
mais à peine est pas encore saison et
ils ont probablement encore de longues
semaines de guerre pour le faire des
semaines de guerre je marque il use et
une détermination affichée mais pas
vraiment l'heure de négocier
non claude pour l'instant pas l'heure de
négocier pas le moment de négocier et
surtout par la moindre lueur d'espoir
pour négocier autant dire c'était un
petit peu paradoxal de voir avec elle en
train aujourd'hui à bruxelles les
ministres des affaires étrangères ont
quand même tenu à réfléchir sur une
future paix dans les balkans
histoire certainement de séduire les
russes de les convaincre que le moment
venu
les russes auront un vrai rôle à jouer
dans la région histoire peut-être aussi
d'avoir évité à s'expliquer sur la
question qui trotte dans toutes les
têtes à l'otan
devra-t-on revenir à la guerre terrestre
quand et surtout comment merci jean marc
certes le temps met en place une force
des deux aux réfugiés du kosovo nous le
verrons dans quelques instants prévoyant
le déploiement de 8000 militaire en
albanie mais pour autant les
bombardements et les raids de l'aviation
des paiements de l'alliance n'ont pas
cessé la nuit dernière à belgrade à
peine chez vos et dans le nord ouest du
pays
les sites industriels ont été touchées
au sud de belgrade un pont ferroviaire à
été bombardées alors passer un train de
voyageurs il y aurait au moins neuf
morts et 16 blessés
la nuit dernière selon l'agent spécial
yougoslave trente six ouvriers de
l'agent ce temps les astana ont été
blessés par des frappes aériennes de
l'otan et cuisses journalistes qui
avaient été filmés en octobre 98
directeur d'un journal indépendant slave
coco de vie chara a été assassiné il
dirigeait un journal daily telegraph à
belgrade journal interdit publication
depuis plusieurs mois le président
jacques chirac est intervenu déjà deux
fois en direct sur les télévisions
depuis le début des frappes de l'otan
sur les télévisions et les radios pour
expliquer l'engagement de la france et
rappelé sa détermination la semaine
dernière il avait très durement mis en
cause monsieur slobodan milosevic
chez les exactions de la police serbe et
on avait noté que monsieur chirac est
avait parlé de milosevic monsieur chirac
recevra demain romano prodi qui doit
bientôt présider la commission
européenne et cet après-midi s'est
entretenu par téléphone avec le
président boris elstsine on sait que la
france souhaite réactiver les contacts
avec moscou pour permettre aux russes de
rentrer dans une négociation
peut-être prochaine avec mel grade nous
le verrons dans quelques instants après
l'intervention du président de la
république en direct de moscou avec
notre correspondant jean raby cloud vont
maintenant écouter l'intervention du
président chirac la troisième depuis le
début des frappes décidée par le temps
sur la serbie monsieur chirac
mes chers compatriotes une nouvelle fois
je voudrais faire le point avec vous sur
le drame du kosovo vendredi dernier le
secrétaire général de l'onu a pris une
initiative qui constitue une nouvelle
étape dans la recherche d'un règlement
politique
ce matin les ministres des affaires
étrangères de l'alliance se sont réunis
après demain les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement des 15 pays de l'union
européenne se retrouveront à bruxelles
et comme je lé souhaitait ils
consacreront l'essentiel de leurs
travaux à la situation au kosovo
face à ce conflit sur le sol européen
l'union européenne doit en effet jouer
tout seul
vous le savez tous aujourd'hui il n'y a
aucun doute sur la responsabilité du
régime serbe qui est à l'origine de
cette crise et qui poursuit
méthodiquement son action criminelle
d'épuration ethnique
ces atrocités dont on ne connaît encore
vraisemblablement qu'une partie ces
cortèges de réfugiés cet immense douleur
qui frappe tant d'enfants de femmes et
d'hommes innocents sont une unique pour
l'europe et une itt pour le monde
aucune femme de coeur aucun homme de
coeur ne peut contester le bien fondé de
la réaction de la communauté
internationale
il fallait mettre terme à une barbarie
qui s'exerce depuis trop longtemps
les opérations que nous conduisons
ensemble commencent à produire leurs
effets que devons nous faire
maintenant il faut savoir maintenir
cette pression militaire sur le régime
serbe aussi longtemps que n'auront pas
été satisfaites de justes exigences
morales et politiques
cette phase est difficile nous
l'assumons le gouvernement et moi-même
la paix ne se gagne qu'après de longs
efforts dans lesquelles la facilité n'a
pas sa place
il faut dans le même temps améliorer et
adapter sans cesse l'aide humanitaire
fournie par la communauté internationale
à plus de cinq cent mille réfugiés
chassés de chez eux par les forces
serbes à l'effort considérable de
solidarité est engagé vous y apporter
une contribution exemplaire que je tiens
une nouvelle fois à saluer il faut aussi
agir en faveur de ceux qui demeurent au
kosovo dont nous connaissons mal la
situation et pour lesquels nous avons
les plus grandes inquiétudes
nous devons trouver d'urgence les moyens
de les aider
il faut enfin renforcer le soutien
apporté aux pays d'accueil
l'albanie la macédoine le monténégro
pour permettre à ces pays de faire face
à l'afflux des réfugiés tout en les
aidant on est dans ces pays à préserver
leur stabilité
mais notre détermination militaire et
notre engagement humanitaire
s'inscrivent dans une perspective plus
large dans une véritable vision
politique et diplomatique ce qui est en
cause c'est l' équilibre même de notre
continent
c'est l'avenir de tous les peuples des
balkans
y compris bien sûr le peuple serbe qui
doivent trouver leur place au sein d'une
europe en paix démocratique et
respectueuse de la dignité humaine
c'est pourquoi nous attachons la plus
grande importance à l'initiative du
secrétaire général des nations unies je
m'en étais entretenu avec lui je m'en
suis également entretenu hier avec le
président clinton avec nos partenaires
européens
et aujourd'hui même avec le président
est elle si ce plan qui donne tout son
rôle à l'onu repose sur quelques
principes simples
déjà exprimée par les alliés principe
autour desquels toute la communauté
internationale pourraient se rassembler
arrêt de la répression et retrait de
toutes les forces serbes du kosovo
retour des réfugiés dans des conditions
de sécurité garantie par une force
internationale
l'ensemble de ces exigences pourraient
ouvrir la voie à un règlement politique
de la crise dès lors qu'elle serait
acceptée sans ambiguïté par les
dirigeants serbes
c'est dire que cette perspective est
encore fragile mais je peux vous assurer
de la détermination de la france à
poursuivre ses efforts tous les
entretiens que j'ai eus au cours de ces
derniers jours font apparaître et c'est
nouveau une large convergence de vues
tant sur le rôle du conseil de sécurité
que sur la nécessaire associations de la
russie dans la recherche d'une solution
politique du conflit
2 conviction que la france vous le savez
défend depuis l'origine c'est dans cet
esprit que les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement de l'union européenne se
réuniront mercredi à bruxelles pour
travailler ensemble sur les différents
aspects de la crise et examiner avec
monsieur kofi annan qui sera présent les
suites à donner à son initiative
mes chers compatriotes
les démocraties doivent être unis et
courageuse l'esprit de munich le
renoncement et la compromission n'ont
jamais apporté que le malheur alors que
nous faisons ensemble tant d'efforts
pour construire l'europe de la paix et
des libertés
nous ne pouvons pas laisser sur notre
continent tant de femmes et d'hommes
victimes de la violence et de
l'intolérance au seul motif de leur race
ou de leur religion
l'histoire nous a hélas appris ou
unetelle acheter pouvaient conduire
c'est pourquoi je suis particulièrement
fier de la générosité de la lucidité et
de la détermination du peuple français
voilà pour l'intervention du président
de la république qui relevait tout à
l'heure c'est qu'il appelait ont tous
une barbarie concernant le sort des
réfugiés du kosovo et chaque journée
nous apporte des images et des
témoignages sur le sort de ces réfugiés
qu'ils soient dans des camps monténégro
en macédoine ou en albanie ce soir c'est
l'histoire d'une enfant de 2 ans
abandonnés dans les désordres de l'exode
au bord d'une route au nord de la ville
de coquettes en albanie commentaires un
vibro zini c'est un bout d'chou d'à peu
près deux ans avec de grands yeux qui ne
regardent pas maman mais une femme une
réfugiée une déportée comme tant
d'autres une femme qui a trouvé la
petite fille ici dans l'une des rues de
cook est la première ville étape à
accueillir le déferlement des kosovars
en albanie elle était assise là dit elle
avec un tee shirt
elle avait quelques bonbons et elle crie
elle n'avait même pas de chaussures
seulement des couches
combien d'enfants comme elles sont ils
perdus anonyme
incapables ne serait-ce que de donner un
nom de famille et que garderont t-il en
mémoire de tout cela ils ont vu deux
terribles choses des scènes violentes
des membres de leur famille assassiné
plusieurs d'entre eux ils n'ont rien ou
quasiment pas l'occasion de jouer bien
sûr que tout cela aura un impact sur sa
mère d'adoption a bien essayé de
questionner la petite fille ou mais
maman dans un camion dit elle elle
ajoute papa papa des mots simples rien
qui puisse guider les gens de l'unicef
pour retrouver les parents rien sur ce
sourire et pour l'heure l'amour de
réfugiés qui use aussi n'ont plus rien
mais le partage encore et puis cette
autre témoignage rapporté par radio
vatican celui du directeur des services
des jésuites pour les réfugiés il faut
savoir que jésuites gère notamment un
camp pour les réfugiés que ce barrage
codra en albanie nous savons pas
personne interposée qu'il y ait eu des
viols de jeunes femmes que les jeunes
femmes les plus belles sont retenus en
serbie il cite notamment le cas de cet
enfant qui ont péri brûlées vives dans
la maison incendiée
je qualifierais des choses qui se
passent dans les camps d'apocalyptique
dit ce père jésuite qui gère donc un
camp à shkodra en albanie derniers
chiffres communiqués par le haut
commissariat aux réfugiés des nations
unies depuis le début de la crise 630
mille personnes ont quitté le kosovo en
macédoine tandisque des kosovars
s'inscrire sur les listes de départ
faute de choix possible faute de pouvoir
retourner vivre au kosovo les militaires
qui avaient mis en place des structures
d'accueil annoncent leur retrait
reportage à ce qu'un de covage de nos
envoyés spéciaux jérôme baugnies et
andré y sera ils ont répondu à l'urgence
en dressant 1000 tentes à quelques
kilomètres du kosovo anker d'abord les
enfants des réfugiés ont eu peur d'eux
comme ils avaient peur des militaires
qui les persécute et au kosovo mais
petit à petit ils se sont habitués
ils ont joué ensemble ils ont oublié la
terreur maintenant pourtant les soldats
français préparent leur départ
va partir tu vois tout les cons il va
face entre va casser tous les barrières
il va y aller parce qu'ils sont faits un
commande une connaissance très amicale
avec lui et si israël soit remplacé par
la police ou des soldats comme ils
disent ici cyrillique
ça veut dire pas les soldats conflit
comment ce dernier il a atteint son pire
cela c'était au 9e art soul et
interprète pour les infirmiers de stands
cobat ils seront bientôt remplacés par
médecins du monde
quand les militaires auront passé la
main à des organisations non
gouvernementales
le contingent français en macédoine n'a
pas vocation à gérer des camps de
réfugiés kosovars
mais il ya pris goût
les soldats français ont formé des
îlotiers en prévision de leur départ
pour faire passer les informations
auprès des familles la coordination du
camp sera reprise par l'association
américaine care dont le responsable
affirme ne pas appréhender le départ des
français
je passe 24 par jour je ne crains pas
pour ma sécurité et j'espère que tous
les gens pour lesquels nous travaillons
pour le même sentiment de sécurité que
moi le départ des français créera un
grand vide dans ce camp où ils sont
restés très présent le plus jour bien
entendu des liens très forts se sont
noués avec les soldats français
ces liens ne sont pas nous et bien
entendu hacker soldats macédoniens qui
sont à l'extérieur et qui apparaissent
comme un peu effectivement une menace un
peu diffuse je crois qu'il n'y a pas
lieu d'être inquiet le cherchons en tout
cas avant de quitter à les rassurer et à
les assurer que nous sommes toujours
présents de façon moins ostensible
quelques hommes devraient rester en
observateur mais cela ne suffit pas à
rassurer ismaël et on craque
ça va se passer là même la même chose
qu'à plate c'est parce que la place et
il y avait des violences et avaient des
matraques les france spécial
macédonienne matraquer les gens les les
autres halls et vieux tous à ceux du
camp à priante se retrouver face à face
avec les policiers macédoniens qui ont
pour ordre d'empêcher les contacts entre
ces réfugiés du kosovo et les albanais
de macédoine
c'est macédonien souvent solidaires
besserve et bien ce même pays de
macédoine dans le président monsieur
gligorov crainte un élargissement du
conflit on a constaté la fermeture de la
frontière côté yougoslave
les militaires français membres de la
force d'interposition surveille la dite
frontière installé dans une zone où les
villages serbes et albanais de macédoine
se côtoient dans un climat tendu
reportage valérie fournit aux et
frédéric basket en macédoine c'est le
poste le plus avancé de l'otan vers les
mines serbe surveillance et vigilance
pour ces français de la 11ème division
parachutiste qui ont vu s'installer les
troupes de milosevic à la frontière des
troupes dont les français peuvent suivre
les mouvements là dernièrement il était
en train encore de dominer l'axé
principal de là également on a vu du
sang t12 et du bob véhicule également
richard quelques pièces antiaériennes et
avec il ya quelques jours des tirs de
missiles c'est dans cette zone que les
trois militaires américains ont été
capturés par les serbes des américains
qui ont envoyé il ya deux jours un
appareil sans pilote photographier les
positions certes réelle on passe votre
côté du mouvement de terrain
85% serbe j'ai le droit aux jets de
cailloux
car dans cette région de la macédoine il
y à des villages serbes et albanais sans
distinction les troupes françaises sont
répartis dans toute cette zone pour que
rien ne leur échappe
toutes informations collectées et
acheminées aussitôt vers le poste de
commandement pour qu'elles soient
ensuite analysées recoupées par les
hommes du renseignement de l'otan dont
qui sont debout et certains sont
agenouillés voir coucher probablement en
train de miner alors ce sera vérifié la
actuellement on est en phase de
surveillance mais si au coup de sifflet
ça devait bouger on est en mesure et
éventuellement de faire notre mini coup
d'arrêt d'envoyer notre missiles et
après ça se saurait mais bien entendu
toujours sur or pour l'instant il n'est
toujours pas question d'intervention en
force de l'otan au kosovo est ici à la
frontière l'observation se poursuit sans
incident entre militaires serbes et
militaires français des militaires
français qui savent bien que c'est une
armée bien entraînés et bien équipée qui
renforce actuellement ses positions à
moins de trois kilomètres en albanie le
président de la république monsieur mais
annie affirme que la guerre va durer
plusieurs mois et évoque le sort de
centaines de milliers d'albanais du
kosovo peut être menacées de famine
selon une représentante du programme
alimentaire mondial de l'onu au port de
douvres rech des navires européens dont
un français ont accosté avait du
matériel et du personnel destiné à
renforcer le dispositif humanitaire
reportage bertrand cocq et roger motte
parti de toulon trois jours plus tôt
l'orage entre ce matin dans le port de
dour s à bord il y a des papiers
les personnels de la sécurité civile et
des militaires
pas loin de 300 hommes en tout et trois
douzaines de véhicules venus renforcer
le dispositif militaro humanitaire
français en albanie et vous savez pour
faire quoi et où
ah je venais à aujourd'hui aux yeux de
mon commandant donc ces pompiers du
sud-est iront peut-être en macédoine ou
peut être pas les ordres ne sont pas
claires ceux là sont fixés ils iront sur
l'aéroport de tirana une star et sapeurs
parachutistes leur mission est
strictement d'ordre humanitaire ce n'est
pas la première fois que la diplomatie
française dispose d'unités combattantes
pour venir en aide à des populations en
difficulté
en général on est utilisée pour faire
d'eux les scores pour faire de la
protection de convois actuellement en
débat
on vient de débarquer on va à tirana on
aura nos ordres sur place mais ce sera
dans l'humanitaire et dans la protection
de convois dans les jours à venir ses
soldats français passeront sans doute
sous commandement de l'otan dans le
cadre d'une vaste opération d'assistance
aux réfugiés kosovars officiellement le
mot d'ordre c'est tout pour
l'humanitaire et rien que l'humanitaire
il n'empêche que cette escalade
humanitaire abouti de fait à une mise
sous tutelle militaire de l'albanie et
de ses 250 mille réfugiés du kosovo où
les serbes de belgrade n'ont pas accès à
une information indépendante et
contradictoires et leur vie quotidienne
est de plus en plus restreinte cet après
midi nous avons enregistré le témoignage
de notre confrère renaud girard l'envoyé
spécial du figaro sur la vie de tous les
jours sous les bombardements dans la
capitale serbe
une vie quotidienne de restrictions ce
n'est pas comme d'habitude car on ne
trouve pratiquement plus décent si vous
voulez l'essence est strictement
rationner ceux qui peuvent avoir de
l'essence ils vont travailler ils
tentent d'organiser leur vie
professionnels comme avant les
bombardements ou est ce qu'il ya une
sorte de ralentissement de l'activité à
d'abord pour les jeunes il faut savoir
que les écoles ou les universités ne
fonctionnent plus les parents qui ont
les moyens qu'ils ont la possibilité ont
souvent préféré envoyer leurs enfants à
la campagne la campagne joue un très
grand rôle en serbie est un pays très
exact hall et donc ils n'ont pas peur de
manquer de produits de base car ils ont
toujours des cousins la campagne dans
les villages qui pourront leur envoyer
des jambons qui ont pourront leur
envoyer delà de la nourriture
en ce qui concerne le travail les les
bus fonctionnent les trolleybus
fonctionnent les tramways également
puisque l'électricité marche même
pendant les bombardements l'électricité
continue à fonctionner avez vous le
sentiment que il les serbes s'installe
comme si cette se confie allait durer
oui alors les bombarde c'est vrai les
bombardements de l'otan n'ont pas fait
fléchir la population et non plutôt
braquer mais en revanche on sent percer
une inquiétude sur deux mecs et une
sourde une inquiétude à long terme car
les gens ici savent tous qu'ils ne
peuvent pas vaincre militairement le
temps qu'il y avait aucune chance de
vaincre militairement et ils ont très
peur de l'avenir
les parents parlent de l'avenir de leurs
enfants par exemple
que deviendront nos enfants plus tard
s'il reste les parias du monde entier et
donc sept îles ont aujourd'hui ils
subissent une sorte de sentiment
d'enfermement
et puis vous avez aussi le paradoxe
d'une jeunesse qui admire plus les
valeurs américaines les films américains
musique américaine et qui par ailleurs
est bombardée par des avions américains
et donc ce ce dilemme ce paradoxe
il leur eux il leur semble très
profondément voilà avec ce témoignage de
renaud girard notre confrère du figaro
qui est en place à belgrade
voilà pour la vie au jour le jour depuis
le début de la crise mais il faut
revenir plusieurs années en arrière pour
comprendre l'état économique et sociale
actuelle de la serbie ce pays s'est
appauvri est isolé le produit national
brut a été divisé par deux avec une
activité industrielle au ralenti rappel
et explications avec jean bernard
schmidt et milan sont de l'état de santé
économique de la serbie depuis
l'éclatement de la yougoslavie jadis
dirigé par le maréchal tito belgrade il
ya quelques jours les images filmées par
une journaliste certes les marchés et
commerces semble bien approvisionné et
apparemment les habitants ne manque de
rien pourtant que l'on ne s'y trompe pas
l'économie serbe est au bord du
précipice
cela fait plusieurs années que le pays
va mal tout l'après guerre et marquer
dans le rêve d'une grande yougoslavie du
maréchal tito un rêve qui passe
notamment par une redistribution
économique entre les régions et plus
riches et les plus pauvres
onze ans après la mort de tito la
slovénie la croatie les deux provinces
les plus prospères proclament leur
indépendance
la yougoslavie se disloque et sombre
dans la guerre
résultat la crise économique s'installe
renforcée par l'embargo décidé en mai 92
par l'onu le chômage atteint 30 % le
salaire moyen est parmi les plus faibles
d'europe
600 francs par mois enfin l'industrie
perd plus de la moitié de sa capacité à
l'image de l' usine de voitures à stava
200 mille véhicules produits en 89 9
milles en 98 d'un point de vue structure
rien est en place les finances publiques
sont dans un état absolument
catastrophique et les dépenses
militaires représentent aujourd'hui un
peu plus de 8% de de la richesse de la
production du pays
milosevic était le choix de la guerre
plutôt que celui des efforts économiques
contrairement à d'autres pays connus
malgré quelques velléités privatisation
rien ne change
le clientélisme gangrène le pays
paralysé la serbie ne survit que grâce
et l'économie parallèle on a une
économie souterraine une économie or le
cadre officiel qui fonctionne qui
fonctionne parce que beaucoup de vue que
cela va à l'étranger parce que il y à
des trafics en tout genre dans cette
région du monde et que ça rapporte bon
que ça ça fait venir de l'argent dans le
pays qui n'est pas prise en compte par
spb cette scic officiel absence de
statistiques fiables opacité des comptes
et des budgets
il est difficile de savoir aujourd'hui
s'il reste de l'argent dans les caisses
de l'état
une certitude les destructions
matérielles infligé chaque hué par les
avions de l'otan affaiblissent un peu
plus le potentiel économique du pays de
la situation au kosovo on ne connaît que
c'est déjà beaucoup que les témoignages
des réfugiés il est très difficile
d'apprécier les positions militaires
serbes les séparatistes de l'uck cheka
qui ont dû se replier aurait reçu des
renforts depuis quelques jours ils
acceptent des équipes de journalistes
pour démontrer leur capacité de
résistance sous leur contrôle et en leur
compagnie voici un extrait d'un document
tourné il y a quelques jours par des
confrères de l'agencé capa en territoire
kosovar
avec les commentaires de benoît duquesne
ces images ont été tournées il y a trois
ou quatre jours au nord ouest du kosovo
dans la région rogova les hommes de nous
ces cas se sont repliés dans les
montagnes qui surplombent la rivière de
la bystrica et qui c'est une patrouille
à nous c'est un de nos commandes et
c'est un leurre bonjour comment ça va
ces hommes reviennent de patrouille un
peu plus bas dans la vallée les lignes
cern ne sont qu'à quelques kilomètres
vivent ils reconnaissent avoir dû
reculer devant l'offensive de milosevic
et compte beaucoup sur l'appui des
forces de l'otan
akon l'intervention de l'otan a changé
quelque chose pour vous oui beaucoup
voit quoi vont ils n'osent plus nous
attaquent avec des charmes et maintenant
qu'est-ce que vous attendez le plus de
l'otan ils nous donnent des armes en
plus les serbes
ce sont des gens comme nous mais c'est
le régime de milosevic
j'ai oppose les serbes et les albanais
et c'est pour ça que je n'ai rien contre
les serbes juste contre milosevic
vous pensez que vous pouvez revivre avec
les serbes comme à lens c'est difficile
moi je ne peux pas dire ça non je ne
crois pas c'est impossible c'est devenu
impossible c'est bon
vous voyez cette route là bas c'est
celle que les serbes utilise
régulièrement ils sont là bas derrière
les rochers
la cepej touba c'est trop dur ma femme
ma famille est là-bas j'ai dû les
quitter depuis longtemps fait l'une des
principales villes du kosovo qu'ils
n'ont plus défendre et que les serbes
ont nettoyé de ses habitants alors
malgré le manque d'armes de nourriture
d'essence les jeunes recrues arrivent
d'europe d'albanie et bien sûr de la
région
vous venez de vous de pécs
ils sont arrivés hier soir ils ont
marché trois jours dans les montagnes
pour nous rejoindre
combien de jeunes arrivent comme ça
chaque jour de 3 500 personnes mais sur
ces images on en verra qu'une
quarantaine c'était le camp
d'entraînement de la 136e brigade de lui
c'est qu'à une brigade qui pour
l'instant reconnaît n'être pas en mesure
d'inquiéter les serbes
le tchèque a qui cherchent à recruter
des militaires en europe mais aussi aux
états unis à new york ils étaient 300
aujourd'hui prêt au départ encadrés par
des officiers de l'armée séparatiste qui
s'inquiètent de la qualité de ces
volontaires et réclament une aide
extérieure reportage à new york
dominique derda ce ne sont encore que
des combattants du dimanche à la
démarche mal assurée aux uniforme
flambant neuf
mais qu'on ne s'y trompe pas ces
kosovars américain qui pour la première
fois ont enfilé la tenue militaire sont
bien déterminés à se battre
bientôt ils iront rejoindre les rangs de
l'ofce qu'à l'armée de libération du
kosovo dans les montagnes d'albanie âgés
de 17 à 60 ans ils sont 300 environ des
hommes et quelques femmes aussi ils
forment ce qu'ils appellent le bataillon
de l'atlantique
le premier contingent de volontaires à
s'envoler pour les baltes en espérons
que le président clinton qui a affiché
sa détermination avec les bombardements
aériens montrera la même détermination
pour armer loup checa cominar mais les
croates lors de la guerre en bosnie
qu'il acceptera enfin d'envoyer des
troupes au sol il sauf que seul sans
l'aide des soldats de l'otan ils ne
parviendront pas à vaincre slobodan
milosevic
ouvriers étudiants peintre en bâtiment
ou laveur de carreaux aucun à
l'expérience de la guerre beaucoup
surtout parmi les plus jeunes sont nés
ici sur le sol américain
quand je vois ces garçons et ces filles
je me sens très fier que dieu les
bénisse et que dieu bénisse l'amérique
la décision pour certains fut facile à
prendre c'était distillent leurs devoirs
j'ai quitté mon travail il y a déjà une
semaine bien sûr mon patron m'a supplié
de rester mais rien ne pouvait me faire
changer d'avis je m'en fiche maintenant
de mon boulot ma femme travaille elle
pourra prendre soin dgos et notre fils
aîné qui à 19 ans reste là pour
s'occuper d'eux sur ce parking au nord
de new york il y en a qui déjà se reste
en héros on ira jusqu'au coeur de
belgrade dit celui-ci planter le drapeau
du kosovo mais ceux qui restent ont bien
compris que de ses combattants tous ne
reviendrait pas derrière la belle
assurance des volontaires le v de la
victoire les larmes d'une soeur d'une
épouse ou d'une mère ne sont jamais bien
loin
à l'heure des adieux plus question de
brava ni de grands discours
c'est un mari qui embrasse sa femme
edith à leur enfant que là-bas au loin
de l'autre côté de l'océan
ils ont une terre celle de leurs
ancêtres et qu'il lui faut la défense
mes chefs me verrais des albanais du
kosovo ibrahim rugova est toujours après
stinat par deux fois le régime de
slobodan milosevic est servie de lui en
annonçant que monsieur hugo va était
défavorable aux actions de le temps mais
un document d'une journaliste allemand
de l'hebdomadaire der spiegel vient
mettre à mal le montage de belgrade
ibrahim rugova n'est pas libre le récit
publié dans le journal le monde
le démontre commentaires marcel trillât
ibrahim rugova était encore pour
quelques jours un homme lit c'était
avenue kléber à paris le 18 mars dernier
la délégation des albanais du kosovo
décide de signer des accords de paix
mais la délégation serbe les rejette
une semaine plus tard les premières
frappes s'abattent sur la serbie est sur
le kosovo peu après à partir du 27 mars
des dizaines de milliers de réfugiés
affluent à la frontière du kosovo en
macédoine au monténégro en albanie
entre-temps ibrahim rugova a rejoint sa
famille dans sa maison de christina
alors que des rumeurs alarmantes
circulent sur son sort
une journaliste allemande renate flotat
au correspondante du spiegel en
yougoslavie lui rend visite le 31 mars
dernier lorsqu'elle veut prendre congé
la maison est cernée par la police serbe
et ses blindés
pendant six jours reinette flotat au se
fait passer pour une parente d'ibrahim
rugova et partage les angoisses de toute
une famille coupé du monde
le soir du premier jour à 20h rue gauvin
et applis le président milosevic veut
discuter d'une solution à la crise
hugo va y consent à contrecoeur est
conscient qu'il n'a pas d'autre choix
le lendemain 1er avril la télévision
yougoslave diffuser ces images qui vont
provoquer la perplexité du monde entier
d'après elle les deux hommes se sont mis
d'accord pour réclamer l'arrêt des
frappes de l'otan
le soir c'est un homme bouleversé les
retrouve les siens à pristina je suis un
président son peuple
quelle carte puis-je encore joué contre
eux belgrade quel sens y at il encore à
rester comme le dernier est roi
christina dans la maison entourée de
policiers on écoute distraitement les
radios des pays occidentaux aux
frontières du kosovo
l'exode s'amplifie rugova ne comprend
pas que l'eau est 6e et puis abandonné
les albanais sans tambour ni trompette
et les livraisons d'essence au boucher
serbe
maintenant le reste de la population va
aussi s'enfuir du kosovo car chacun rêve
de s'installer à l'ouest
aucun ne reviendra piégée à christine à
ibrahim rugova bien compris la manoeuvre
de slobodan milosevic le faire passer
auprès de son peuple pour un traître
le 5 avril nouvelle mise en scène
orchestrée par même grave
ibrahim rugova reçoit la visite de
l'ambassadeur de russie accompagnés de
nombreux journalistes
reinette flotat au profitera de leur
départ pour s'éclipser à foix de pouvoir
témoigner
parmi les initiatives diplomatiques
celle du secrétaire général de l'onu
monsieur kofi annan qui s'est déclaré
prêt à rencontrer slobodan milosevic
cette initiative et le soutien des
gouvernements de le temps monsieur
jacques chirac président de république
l'a rappelé tout à l'heure mais à
belgrade pour l'instant pas de réponse
c'est donc vers moscou que se tourne
maintenant l'action diplomatique
monsieur chirac a eu un entretien
téléphonique avec monsieur yale signer
des pays européens poussent à remettre
la russie dans le champ des négociations
gide rabin cet appel à la russie est il
bien reçu à moscou tout à fait la
situation n'a jamais été aussi favorable
pour la russie depuis le début des
frappes
d'autant plus favorable claude que la
grande menace politique qui pesait sur
boris ici vient d'être levée cette
menace était jeudi prochain le débat en
procédure de destitution qui faisait
contre le président boris et s'il est
bien la question est renvoyée sine
aidiez l'entourage de monsieur primakov
le premier ministre a fait valoir que
l'entremise de la russie étaient
sollicités de toutes parts que la
gravité de la situation internationale
réclamée une russie forte ce qu'elle
n'aurait évidemment pas pu être avec un
président profondément déstabilisé alors
cependant madame hoelbrak la secrétaire
d'état des états unis a été très
prudente avant sa rencontre donne un os
clos avec le ministre affaires
étrangères russe monsieur ivanoff mais
vous savez madame brad parcours avant le
russe elle l'est elle même les journaux
russes elle est donc parfaitement au
courant de l'ampleur et de la violence
de la crise politique intérieure en
russie madame aubry connaît aussi très
bien il ya brillé primakov bien qu'il
soit adversaire par la force des choses
il partage depuis longtemps une
véritable amitié personnelle et c'est
donc que la politique de milosevic
représente exactement ce contre quoi
primakov a toujours lutté toute sa vie
en union soviétique d'abord puis en
russie comme chef des services secrets
comme chef de la diplomatie comme chef
du gouvernement aujourd'hui est qu'on
peut qualifier d'un mot le nationalisme
rouge brun mais madeleine albright sait
aussi que l'un des grands paradoxes de
la vie politique intérieure russes c'est
que le gouvernement primakov à
aujourd'hui
absolument besoin à la douma du soutien
de ces gens là aussi les communistes
nationalistes de russie qui sont tous
des inconditionnels de milosevic et cela
vous donne claude une idée des limites
très étroites de ce que peut faire la
russie merci gilles sur les frappes de
l'otan sur la volonté constante des pays
qui apportent leur soutien matériel à
ses frappes et réactions des opinions
publiques européennes sont parfois
contrastés les manifestations pacifistes
ne cesse pas cependant le sort des
réfugiés kosovars suscite très
majoritairement une expression de
solidarité voici comment en allemagne en
angleterre et en italie réagissent les
opinions publiques autant que l'on
puisse s'appuyer sur les sondages plus
de trois britanniques sur quatre
approuvent la participation de leur pays
aux frappes de l'otan et ce soutien n'a
pas faibli depuis le début du conflit
mais ça ne signifie pas pour autant que
les pacifistes à londres reste
silencieux un mille personnes défilaient
d'ailleurs hier dans la capitale à
l'appel d'organisations d'extrême côté
solidarité la croix rouge britannique et
les autres organisations humanitaires
trouve sous les dons mais en revanche
très peu de sujets de sa majesté sont
prêts à héberger des kosovars
ils chiffrent en cela la position de
leurs gouvernements
quant à une éventuelle offensive
terrestre et bien 47 % des britanniques
sont pour aujourd'hui c'est un chiffre
en très forte et très rapide
augmentation l'opinion publique
italienne est majoritairement contre la
guerre et ce depuis le premier jour du
conflit
résultat d'un sentiment pro serbe
traditionnelle en italie résultat aussi
d'un courant pacifiste l'attend depuis
la fin de la seconde guerre mondiale
anti militaristes et anti fascisme vont
de pair résultats enfin d'une
conjonction étrange entre deux courants
d'idées important les communistes sont
contre la guerre et les catholiques sont
aussi contre la guerre alors tout cela
traduit par des manifestations
pacifistes dans tout le pays en
particulier à bari juste en face de la
yougoslavie
cette région des pouilles qui souffrent
économiquement du conflit avec ses
aéroports fermés et à tourisme en crise
alors l'italie maillon fragile de l'otan
c'est bien possible
les servent le savent bien qu'ils ont
laissé les journalistes italiens à
belgrade et qui se sont bien gardés de
rompre leurs relations diplomatique avec
rome
les allemands qui participent pour la
première fois depuis la fin du troisième
reich à des bombardements
en europe hors de leurs frontières cela
évidemment a créé un climat tout à fait
particulier dans le pays d'abord parce
que la vision des choses n'est pas tout
à fait la même
à l'ouest et dans l'ex allemagne de
l'est on voit bien au niveau des
sondages si au total 64 % des allemands
sont pour la poursuite des frappes
la réaction n'est pas tout à fait la
même dans l'ex-allemagne de l'est le
différentiel est de plus de 14 fois un
climat très particulier également depuis
que les premiers réfugiés du kosovo sont
arrivés sur place ils sont plus de dix
mille aujourd'hui seront peut-être vingt
mille en fin de semaine mais les
allemands font preuve aujourd'hui de bon
coeur de générosité d'hospitalité la
croix-rouge croule actuellement sous les
offres d'hébergement climat politique
également très particulier on observe
que les pacifistes sont quasiment
inexistants ils ont certes organisé une
petite manifestation la semaine dernière
à berlin mais ils n'étaient que 15000
cela dit si les conflits de v devait se
poursuivre eh bien les pacifistes
pourrait se réactive et 79 % des
allemands sont aujourd'hui contre une
intervention terrestre
16 % seulement sont favorables voilà
pour l'actualité au kosovo actualités
sur lesquels reviendront
arlette chabot et alain duhamel dans
l'émission mots croisés à partir de 23h
ce soir sur france en algérie dernières
heures de campagne électorale en vue des
élections présidentielle dont le premier
tour a lieu le 15 avril sept candidats
sont en lice l'un d'eux a dû être
hospitalisé c'est monsieur hocine aït
ahmed un autre monsieur bouteflika part
largement favori contre ampute de ses
derniers moments de campagne en algérie
avec thierry thulliez et bruno girodon
compte rendu de ceux de ces dernières
heures de campagne que nous allons
pouvoir observer en compagnie de nos
envoyés spéciaux qui a étudié et bruno
girondeau concernant la campagne
électorale en algérie puis on vient
d'apprendre par une dépêche officielle
datée du gouvernement d'alger que dix
personnes ont été assassinées à mascara
c'est dans l'ouest algérien donc les
assassinats continuent malgré la
campagne électorale et les annonces
faites par tous les candidats de régler
la crise algérienne reportage de thierry
thulliez et bruno girodon team la paix
c'est le slogan des militants du parti
islamiste hamas qui a appelé à voter
pour le favori du scrutin de la visite
technique
un grand écart annie sans état d'âme par
messieurs présents au meeting du
candidat
après c'est comme ça
il était
il ya là tous les appareils officiel fln
les syndicats qui draine une foule à la
motivation pas évidente pour cent il ne
s'est pas de vous tous les rangs et
c'est vrai qu'il est moins question du
programme que de la personnalité du
candidat abdelaziz bouteflika promet
d'être le patron qui manque à l'algérie
depuis la mort de houari boumédiène et
celui que l'ancien front islamique du
salut soutient officiellement à lévis
brahimi plusieurs fois ministre c'est
que c'est la mobilisation de l'électorat
islamistes qui peut lui permettre d'être
présent au deuxième tour dans sa
campagne
la réconciliation comme condition à la
paix revient comme un leitmotiv l'état
que je propose de construire garantira
le pain et la sécurité en algérie chez
les militants l'arrêt des violences
passe par la fin de la diabolisation de
lexus
si les textes fils acceptent le jeu de
la démocratie acceptent de voter pour
monsieur table et brahim en acceptant
vraiment les règles du jeu alors je suis
avec eux partout dans le pays la
provoquer le même intérêt
mouloud hamrouche le réformateur a mené
campagne en parlant de justice
indépendante d'état de droit de
neutralité de l'armée
son franc-parler a plu à des foules
toujours plus au monde
la meilleure j'avertis l'opinion
publique et les pouvoirs publics que les
conséquences des fraudes massives
ce seront très graves est catastrophique
pour le pays et pour le pouvoir c'est
l'absence qui risque de peser lourd
hocine aït ahmed malade a dû abandonner
la campagne et personne ne sait quel
sera l'effet sur son électorat
jamais aucune campagne électorale en
algérie n'a paru aussi ouverte
pourtant une fois encore beaucoup
d'algériens craignent la fraude et on
sentiment que les jeux sont déjà faits
avant même d'aller voter
comme si l'algérie était condamné au
surplace quand il est question de
démocratie à pau dans les
pyrénées-atlantiques première journée
d'actions de protestation contre un plan
de suppression d'emplois dans une unité
du groupe pétrolier elf un plan de
restructuration qui prévoit la perte de
2000 emplois dont un millier en béarn
plan dénoncé par le personnel de cette
unité des veaux elf reportage david
bazié philippe gmail c'est une décision
il le durcissement du conflit conclut
les salariés grévistes d'elf aquitaine
en occupant cette parabole
ils privent les services d'études de
toute communication avec l'extérieur
notamment avec les filiales étrangères
la manière forte ou refuser les dix
mille suppressions d'emplois annoncées
par le pdg philippe jaffré dans le béarn
le berceau d'elf aquitaine
la politique c'est de faire le maximum
pour l'actionnaire quand on veut servir
14 % de rendement sur les actions et
quand on sait que l'économie mondiale
avance sur un rythme de progression de 2
4% en voit de suite la difficulté et
c'est à ce titre là que la seule
variable qui existe c'est au niveau de
l'emploi
et c'est pour cette raison que cette
politique est menée à notre sens quand
le président jaffray la direction reste
ferme et attend le 16 avril pour
communiquer précisément ses intentions
la semaine dernière à paris elle a tout
simplement éconduit trois élus locaux
dont françois bayroux président du
conseil général et andré labarrère le
maire socialiste de pau résultats
sentiment de trahison chez les grévistes
qui ont taggé le bureau du maire
un élu qui dénoncent aujourd'hui les
méthodes de la multinationale elle se
sent à la fois de monter d'un bon on
sert à rien des politiques c'est une
entreprise privée l'état est parti donc
on n'a pas à s'intéresser aux aigus
c'est le sentiment de dédain enfants
sert à rien au pot pour le brisant
jaffré le désengagement d'elf aquitaine
menace une grande part de l'économie
locale samedi prochain les grévistes les
élus les commerçants une bonne partie de
la population se retrouveront pour une
manifestation qui s'annonce virulent
publication par l'insee de l'indicé des
prix à la consommation ils ont augmenté
de 0 4% en france en mars par rapport à
février ce qui fait une augmentation de
0 4% sur un an
la vente de france soir à l'homme
d'affaires george ghost est devenu
effectif vers en effet du conseil
d'administration de france heures pour
cette session du journal à clermont
ferrand l'ancien patron d'une usine de
produits isolants été mis en examen pour
empoisonnement cette mise en examen fait
suite aux plaintes de plusieurs salariés
de cette usine qui souffrent de maladies
dues à l'amiante la décision du juge
d'instruction est une première en france
le tribunal correctionnel de bordeaux a
prononcé deux condamnations de prison
ferme à l'encontre de deux accusés du
procès de la gestion du club de football
des girondins
le juge baum irb à rennes et didier
couécou ont été condamnés pour des
surfacturations transferts de joueurs
deux ans de prison dont 20 mois avec
sursis pour didier couécou les deux
hommes devraient faire appel enfin ce
soir pour terminer ce journal à paris au
new morning
un concert de jazz avec cai et soude il
est à la contrebasse et il a un nom
difficile à porter puisqu'il est le fils
de clint eastwood dans la famille on ne
fait pas le même métier mais on apprécie
en commun le jazz rencontre avec kyle
eastwood avec michel mompontet bernard
gonflé
contournez choisi d'être musicien avoir
un faussaire avec quelqu'un de connu
c'est gênant
et
sauf bien sûr quand c'est le faussaire
de papa et que papa et souvenez vous il
ya dix ans le film en quittant cannes le
grand clint apprenez deux accords de
guitare un gentil blondinet inconnu
c'est une ligne et kyle eastwood a
grandi on peut pas dire qu'il m'est
forcé mais il y avait toujours des
disques de jazz sur la platine alors ça
m'a guidé la spar est donc devenu fan et
depuis peu s'est mise au piano
pour kyle eastwood difficile de grandir
loin de l'ombre tutélaire de papa papa
joue du piano
jamais en public mais on fait parfois le
boeuf dans le salon
on a coutume de dire que la contrebasse
et le course de maman mais avec la voix
du pape a pas facile à supporter
psychanalytiquement mais musicalement
cas ils lui sont deux très bien s'en
sortir
non
et tous
m
avant de refermer ce journal je vous
rappelle les informations concernant
l'actualité au kosovo est tout d'abord
l'intervention du président jacques
chirac c'était à 20h troisième
intervention depuis le début du conflit
monsieur chirac a insisté sur les
atrocités criminels l'épuration ethnique
at il dit il a évoqué la honte et la
barbarie qu aux airs et aux réfugiés que
devons nous faire maintenant et bien
tout d'abord il a salué la contribution
exemplaire de la france et de la
solidarité internationale et aussi
encourager l'action du secrétaire
général des nations unies monsieur kofi
annan la france donc appuyé cette action
est réintroduit dans sur unis mais aussi
moscou pour un espoir de règlement
diplomatique les alliés font donc bloc
ils l'ont fait tout en continuant des
bombardements puisque aujourd'hui les
alliés les l'aviation de l'otan a
bombardé à un pont il ya un train passer
sur ce point il ya neuf morts et sans
doute un nombre indéterminé de blessés
le temps a obtenu cette action tandis
que madame madeleine albright paix se
trouve est aujourd'hui à la réunion du
ministère des affaires étrangères les
pays membres de l'otan des 19 pays et
que l'on évoquait de nouveau le sort des
réfugiés dans les camps de macédoine et
d'albanie ainsi que le rôle de look
chekade dont nous vous avons montré un
document exceptionnel document tourné au
kosovo dans un instant la météo de
nathalie rihouet à 20h55
quelle histoire une nouvelle émission
présentée par william l'énergie pour
découvrir l'histoire le parcours de
personnes de familles de de lieux ou de
communautés au destin étonnant c'est
avec william leymergie et puis à 22h55
mots croisés spécial kosovo arlette
chabot et alain duhamel recevront
bernard kouchner alain madelin et
charles pasqua notamment pour débattre
de cette actualité du kosovo à 0 à 35 le
dernier journal jeu sera présenté par
florence du praj sera suivie du cercle
de philippe lefait et demain c'est 1,50
dans les 4 vérités françoise laborde
recevra alain madelin le président de
démocratie libérale à 13h vous
retrouverez rachid arhab à demain 20h
dans soir merci